it's just got a bit of a stickier kind
of attitude you know in intensive you
know kind of gets an air kick it causes
some issues and we're working on that
right now I have good friends that are
really starting to crack this code and
we are very [ __ ] close to coming up
with treatment and very close to come up
with a virus in this country which you
are not from so that's an important
thing for our little realize is that you
are a bonafide
a bona fide weasel activist aka a
communist from the north of [ __ ]
kanata yeah and and will take your
country over if we want so that's the
other thing
yeah what you're more American than me I
agree with number one you were born on a
ship in Singapore [ __ ] you and then your
dad dragged you over in your diapers and
then you went to [ __ ] whatever sort
of weird boarding boarding school
snatched by [ __ ] girls on the rest of
real kid will the real concession just
decided to be an American I decided I
made the choice but I didn't just slip
out out you know what I [ __ ] decided
I'm coming down here I'm taking my
Canadian flag I'm taking my World
Championship and I'm coming down there
I'm Way more American than you Brian
as a matter of fact come May 15th let's
do this apple-pie me [ __ ] you
challenging you right now as soon as
this [ __ ] lockdown is lifted
apple pie eating contest or we can do it
outside in the park six feet of park but
you have to wear that ass can eat apple
pie you son of a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] show
you how because I'm more American than
you use the son of a [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ] joke down a [ __ ] steak after
that that's right I'll have a Texas meat
dessert after my apple pie a Texas meat
dessert god Dan oh well you took us a
task here you got on this [ __ ]
vodcast
via little
who you want that for and if you want us
the riot act and you're accusing us of
being uncovered safe because well you
know what Brian here let me let me
actually let me do this watch your words
awesome words 23 year old whiskey which
has been proven proven Cheers lab to
[ __ ] kill covetous [ __ ] tracks
how's that water yeah why don't you
stick a blow dryer in your mouth - isn't
it busy doesn't that work that does work
knows what so does going to church and
so does going to [ __ ] church keep
going this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]